high-pitch Eric showed up outside our
office with his brand-new truck surely
met him downstairs Eric wanted to fool
around with our writer Chris Wilding in
the back of the truck Eric told Shirley
what he likes about Chris and then he
revealed something shocking about his
own body but you know we kind of knew
this but I guess we forgot what is it
about Chris that you love so much
he's got soft hands touched your penis
right yeah I watch this did you get a
hard-on I did so are you not sure you
know my ball sacks are inverted inverted
so I couldn't tell I think he means his
peanut Hey well he said his ball sacks
are inverted I think he's got multiple
ball sacks
hey Chris did you feel like like you
were like helpless Oh completely we he
opens the back of the truck right
flatbed truck I get into it for god
knows what reason but you're praying to
it and we're just sitting and we're
looking up at the sky you know the
middle of New York six evident yeah and
very casually he just puts his right leg
over me over my torso and that was I
mean I then you realize oh [ __ ] this guy
is like a monster yeah like Of Mice and
Men that lady
Lenny yeah like just you know like he
could stroke your hair and just you know
take your head off yeah he got you back
in the truck along with that boy how'd
you get out of the car with Eric did you
tell him to let go are you and so the
only way I really got out of it and by
the way as I was getting out of it he
grabbed my car
I gotta go I agreed to go with him on
Valentine's Day to go see Sesame Street
Live nah that's great you're gonna plan
the date
why Sesame Street
so you did he buy the tickets or did you
I'm not [ __ ] buying dick I'm clearly
the woman in this relation